heute bin ich mal was dabei da darf kein
fernsehteam mit dass sie hinter mir ist
das e werk in der nähe da sieht man es
da harald schmidt show wird ja auch
produziert und im e werk tritt patrice
auf da kann man wechselt stehen das ist
schon mal sensationell aber das beste
kommt hinterher und zwar gibt es einen
blitz so aber jetzt erstmal was das ist
wenn man dann im laufe dieses videos
erfahren aber jetzt erstmal ins konzerte
und ein geplatzter
denn hinter der bühne beendet batterie
sein konzert mit dem song walking alone
es ist mitternacht und jetzt geht unsere
geschichte erst richtig los wir machen
einen auf mtv cribs im tourbus
da kommt
das aufgeräumt
amos wurden habe ich nicht
aufgeräumt aber hier kann man sich ja
unter anderem noch eine lounge niveau
mal ist immer super
zweimal wenden
selig hatte die sogenannte
hsg oha die scheiben verdunklungs
sensation
das anders wo gehen wir mal jeder
flatscreen und berater
aber kein zufall heraus gucken
ja super hier lässt sich's leben wie
lange wir mehr als einem monat fast 2
und da müsst ihr euch aber verstehen
oder wegen defekten
alles gut
solange der einheit vor dem alarms haben
dann geht es hier
gut ausschauen
so patrice wo geht es denn jetzt fahren
wir zum blitz ging
und der ist wo er ist am brüsseler platz
wir sind schon alle da und ich glaube es
ist schon alles angerichtet
wie sind die idee entstanden so was zu
machen ich meine damen geht also ich
würde vielleicht ins hotel gehen an die
bei
den kollegen der ijn manager richtig
es ist ein freund von mir der sich ein
herz zu herz gefasst hat wirklich gesagt
hat das kann so nicht weitergehen mit
dir das kann ich mich mal angucken ich
schreibe jetzt alt und ich gehe davon
aus dass meine idee war aber das ist ja
total
auch in der natur
aber es ist auch egal wie es wirklich
ist das gut zusammen egal was ich gar
nicht wenn der kleine erfolgsmomente ist
ein kunde sagt einfach mal was momentan
ist machen die anderen gewerke nicht so
auf alles planen und so einfach mit dem
was da es arbeiten und gucken was
passiert
und da entstehen auf viele neue ideen
für neue songs und so weiter und viele
jam sessions wir hatten eine in
frankfurt mit aloe blacc wir haben
einige macht in stuttgart gerade mit max
herre und das ist macht spaß
und vieles was geht ab meine helden auf
der bühne so dass ich immer viel jeder
hat jeder der in der stadt ins konzert
vorbei und ist
total unheil sondern ist einfach so der
jazzclub paar instrumente jemand der
schlagzeug spielen kann setzt das
schlagzeug
auf der gitarre und ja man macht einfach
was spaß macht
das erleben wir jetzt gebrochen
bescheinigung gebe noch keine
bescheinigung sie sind sie aus wie et es
gibt
wohl tätig war
keller des hallen macken reuter so heißt
die klavier komponiert patrice live ins
mikrofon der passende titel i'm gonna
ride wissen
also
sie sollte
wie kommt man locker